for the first time ever 33 floors of the
Empire State Building were transformed
into a glowing canvas
images of the world's most threatened
mammals insect and sea creatures stood
tall over the concrete jungle for one
night only wails snow leopards and
chameleons were projected in standing 5k
resolution but it wasn't an easy feat
behind the lens obscured digital a SAN
francisco-based company stacked 40
20,000 lumen projectors on the roof of a
nearby building but why blow 1 million
dollars on a stunt like this well to
call attention to the upcoming
television release of Discovery's
documentary racing extinction the series
is directed by luis de Hoyos the
oscar-winning director of The Cove in
that film size is used infrared cameras
drones and custom software to reveal the
slaughter of dolphins in Taiji Japan so
it should be no surprise that for the
new series the director has again turned
to hi-tech to achieve his message about
the role of humans in the current age of
mass extinction